this man against my head a second ago
what eat your liver freeze them I hope
so I hope so
I'm getting old cuz I need it for our
die I'm getting old
I honestly want one I'm not the thing is
why I wouldn't seek for one is
organically I'm game
I wouldn't try and patent one yeah it's
not it's just not the same all census
yeah into it yeah I don't know how about
yourself
I don't forgot ever yeah I obviously
said I want one yeah
never gonna happen never gonna happen
you and I can't be asked like you said
try yeah and when I talk to
sorry it's cut you off when I talk to
certain girls I'm not something kills
one when sometimes when girls ask me if
I've had a threesome or if I turn with
I've never had freezin they're surprised
and shows how have you never had a
freeze and blah blah blah and I'm
thinking like a lot that girls that I've
said it to me that they have had some I
like between that 2024 range well me 20
between 20 24 that was eight years ago
so for me it wasn't it's not this if I
was 20
now I will probably freedom now do not
mean because sex is different yeah yeah
eight years ago sex we obviously people
having reasons but it wasn't I was even
more a exactly I was just right a bank
not even try to get a lips yeah
threesome was not fun yes 2011 like come
on it's not it's not the same it's not
the same that's probably a reason why
and I've been a lot relationships so I
don't one if your relationship obviously
for obvious reasons
you know reasons are just an invalid
topic I remember T same again T when I
was with T I told you that she's the gas
stating she was the she's the lie she's
still out all the time unprovoked oh my
eyes she used to say all the time that
are when it's your birthday will get
like I don't know what she said will get
like a pro something yeah and then we'll
have a threesome and I was like gang I
come here I'm he
yeah cuz I'm all over it never [ __ ]
have AB never happened it was never
gonna happen
yeah she just yeah she'd like to get
inside my mom shot yeah it's one of them
ones really like you said I don't Jenny
I think I had my opportunity and I lost
it mmm and that one time mmm and I don't
think he's ever gonna rise again yeah
same well I've not had the opportunity
but I just don't feel like the edge
there
the opportunity will come yeah there's
I'm saying like that time where it
didn't happen for me mmm but those two
goes yeah that was the way I went that
way I'm talking about we just said like
organic and that was the way it was
supposed to happen yeah it never
happened and I kind of just I just need
to wash my hands of it now I need to
wash my hands of it oh [ __ ] but I would
love one though mmm yeah even if it
wasn't dope it would still be dope yeah
of course if it wasn't the buffest girls
or like the buffest scenario but you can
at least say you've had a reason you can
do you just like the tick [ __ ] off list
yeah no an imaginary listeners nice to
tick off I'm not that fast I was like
when I was a lot younger but not fast by
say I was more enthusiastic about it but
I don't really care that much
yes true where we went to Miami yeah
when we were children and children on
the plane over we read a list of all
this so for context the fellas we all
went there was five of us we went to
Miami mover just turned 21 rude little
turn 21 [ __ ] children yeah and we've
convinced ourselves like Miami where
it's at we wrote a list on the flight
over there of all the [ __ ] we're gonna
do like uh what was it yeah like our
free sundaes and it started off light
like lips ago girl girls number [ __ ] ago
then threesome and they
like all the things you can imagine was
on the list yeah and it was like a point
system right yeah and we've had the most
points at the end we're inside I don't
forget you won't get any points we went
in 2012 we were young children children
absolutely - Jen I didn't know what the
[ __ ] was going on and yeah it was
pathetic that's what we actually gonna
accomplish you know no one was going
Miami back then as well I was vexed I
remember the year off that everyone on
Instagram where Miami perfume it and it
couldn't look live it alive I was fuming
I feel like we just like we paved the
way and then every one of we did but we
did it so wrong so wrong we've yeah yeah
yeah naive is what it was we did it so
wrong we needed money found we tried to
live celebrity Miami life on on a
minimum wages student loan gonna Bob it
didn't pop at all it was the worst best
I'd ever worst best holiday yeah I said
[ __ ] amazing let me talk you about his
finger I was awkward the other day yeah
and I've got into conversations go about
marriage okay and it got out there not
out there but it got like in depth in
depth and obviously I've never really I
thought well I'm probably most likely
definitely gonna get married yeah but I
don't want to get married for the sake
of I don't want to get married for the
reasons people would assume one person
would want to be be married okay I don't
want to get married to be married yeah I
would just end up getting married to
make the person happy okay and I would
enjoy the wedding
yeah but the sanctity of marriage to me
is not it doesn't anybody so I was
intrigued yeah because especially since
you come of more of a traditional
background than I do yeah what you're
just another don't say like that but
yeah yeah yeah nobody you mean though
you do you do know what you mean so for
what was like what what what what's your
mindset on marriage I what you so much I
want to get married but I'm single right
now so it's not in my forefront but as
it's
the reason why is the reason I want to
get married is because I I for one I
love the sanctity of you like I I want
to know that I have made one person
happy and she makes me happy kind of
thing and then we just ride out into the
sunset yeah that kind of thing yeah yeah
I'm not forcing I'm not out actively
searching for it hmm like if like three
something I want to happen organically
mm-hmm
and a lot of people females especially
not necessary to rush into marriage but
feel pressured intimated especially
African females purely because of the
culture system they all I was talking to
with African first on it makes sense
yeah it does it speaks volumes because
one obviously their biological clock in
terms of having kids and blah blah blah
more more so their parents mm-hmm a lot
of their parents once to see grandkids
hmm and want them to witness their
weight in a blood they feel a lot more
pressured but for a guy it's different
because we've got not really got a
biological clock we can get married any
time you want it doesn't really affect
us that much so for context my sister's
married she's got a kid and as soon as
as soon as she got married as soon as
got engaged my parents not asked me our
wedding you got to get married well
that's tough I'm like don't force me to
get married because at the end of day
it's my life it's not you as I
understand it it's coming from a loving
place but it it does concern you but in
the long term it actually doesn't
concern you kind of thing because at the
end of a if once I get married that's
probably me out of your life you you'll
be done with it you know I mean so don't
force it don't let it happen organically
and let me find peace and what I want to
find because nine times I tell me
somethings forced or like something's
rushed you're just gonna go into it for
the wrong reasons I'm just gonna feel
like let me just do it because I just
want to settle down oh I'm done blah I
just want to find that person but you
can't just actively go out and find that
person it matters it you're just forcing
your life it just happens mmm once you
go in a couple of days he feel like this
person pretty cool boy you just managed
to find that person but like I said in
like three episodes ago or two episodes
ago African backgrounds back then so our
parents generations think differently to
this current African gender
so my parents have known each other
since they were teenagers they went to
the same school all of that stuff and
they made each other since they were
like 12 13
around that age and my mom is 62 my dad
64 almost 63 64 so that's over 50 years
or roughly 50 years you mean prized so
for them and obviously technology there
was no technology back then there was no
phones there was no internet there was
no none of that so all they had was that
communication and that's all they knew
you so they had to go out and link they
had to go out yeah I mean so for them
and it's the same I've seen in England
as well but for back in Africa is
completely different in Africa compared
to any Western civilization so for them
that's all they know and that's the
reason why a lot of African parents have
known their partners for X amount of
years because that's all they knew they
were brought with that so when they
moved over here they still adopted that
culture in terms of you have not you
have necessarily find someone but nine
times out of 10 African parents once you
might want you to marry in African mmm
not predominate and ideally where you're
from as well so my my mum would ideally
like me to marry a Nigerian because I'm
majoring yeah because of the
adaptability of it mm-hmm for the kids
which is understandable but my mum knows
me now like it's not necessary because I
don't want to marry a Nigerian I'm not
gonna marry a Nigerian it's just because
I am NOT I take pride in my heritage but
I'm not actively around Nigerians yeah
what a day-to-day basis yes to even
attempts to find a Nigerian hmm I was
when I lived in London and I was when I
was in my secondary school and you knew
and all that because that's the crowd I
was with and that's the crowd I was
around yeah
obviously when you move out of that city
and move out of that complex or comfort
zone per se you experience other things
and they've succumbed to the fact that
98 like I said in the other episode I'm
most like probably not going to marry
Nigerian and my parents have succumb to
that because they'd much rather me be
happy with whoever I'm happy with rather
than forcing me per se in Samoa and
Nigerian and maybe not miserable but
just be content with life yeah yeah
exactly
why be content when you
be happy yeah well that's basically what
the conversation was about or that we
were having mm-hm was more in terms of
yes being happy with the person but
basically how do I describe it so basic
what what her example basically is she
used mmm
was that she had a she started asking me
sushi was out do you think you're gonna
get married
mmm and I was like mmm I don't really
give a [ __ ] if I could get married or
not mmm but I said if I do it'll be to
make my partner happy mm-hmm because I
could take or leave it to me
okay and she said why is that and I said
because basically the way I feel I don't
feel like I need marriage to show how I
feel about oh yeah and I don't feel like
I don't ever want to be in a
relationship in where anything changes
from the day before married to the day
after we were married okay
so she was trying to say the best she
had a situation where she got cheated on
okay
and she was living with the guy Wow and
he cheated on her and then won one of
his justifications or one of his reasons
reasons was that they're not married and
I was like that's why bro bro she said
that and I was like she was like well he
had a point not like me doesn't boy so
she's trying to say if he cheated on her
the day before the wedding that's fine
bro she's basically trying to say she
thinks that he'll be less likely to
cheat if they were married that's stupid
and basically what she was trying to say
is that marriage like is it's got more
sanctity to it which I can understand
especially from more traditional
standpoint yeah it has more sanctity to
it but I don't think it should she I
said like basically I said the reason
why I wouldn't want to get married or
one of the things that will stop me from
getting married is because it's more
complicated to leave someone when you're
married and not just saying because I
want to leave someone but why I am
trying to say is that I would feel more
grass
fight in my life making it as easy as
possible for my partner to leave me at
the drop of a hat
mm-hmm so that I know when they've
stayed with me for all this time is
because they well and truly wanted to
yeah not because we have a house and
kids and paperwork and it's gonna cost
this much to do it because she was
talking about like ah she lives she said
like ah yeah well when you've got all
these things like you've changed your
name and you son listen to her yeah she
was like you might think twice before
doing something that you you might do in
a relationship and I was like yeah but I
don't want I don't want my wife thinking
twice yeah if she's gonna do something
don't want to do if you want to suck
some guy's dick going suck his dick in
him like don't think twice about the
formalities of our situation yeah if you
want to cheat on me
cheat on me if you want to leave Leave
like I want to be with someone who wants
to be with me yeah and I said like she
was like yeah no but obviously you've
made and I said also is that I wouldn't
want the vows and the tradition of
marriage to to hold someone back from
living their best life okay so if for
example so what I was trying to say is
is I don't in this day and age
especially I don't necessarily always
think it's fair to make a promise to
someone like you said your parents are
known each other for for 50 years so I
don't expect to be the same person I am
today in 50 years time yeah and I
wouldn't I don't think it's fair for me
to expect someone to hold a promise to
someone they knew fifty years ago and
keep that promise fifty years later when
I could be a completely different person
so when I was 18 for example I was in 28
now when I was 18 I was a different
person yeah so if I have married someone
on when I was 18 the values and the
personality and all this stuff that I
have now could be completely different
it was a double yeah it is completely
different how I was when I was 18 yeah
so let's say the girl that I'm with we
get married we get married when we're 18
I turn into the guy I am today yes
she stays exactly the same yeah we don't
have any common interest we don't really
get along we don't necessarily even like
each other anymore
it's not fair for me to expect her to
uphold the promise to the person there
was example I'm not the same yeah and
ideally yes you want to meet the person
that you grow
together with ya so hopefully like I was
saying to her like it's fair I'm like
Thank You Bridget from school mmm when
using school you might have had 1520 of
your boys there you're all best friends
and then everything is blessed yeah and
then now we're you nearly 30 you might
have like two of them left yeah of
course but there's no hard feelings
about that life yeah that's just life
you just grew apart and you different
people said why would you stay together
why would you still be friends just
because your friends in school yeah like
that's dumb it is it's just gonna make
everyone unhappy yeah and I feel the
same way that about a relationship like
okay I see sua come down the line of
with different people yeah I don't want
you to feel obliged yeah when you're
like when you come home from work and
think I don't actually even like this
guy like he's not the same guy and it's
not necessarily a bad thing that he's
not the same guy but it's just not I
don't love this guy yeah like it's just
not it's just not him who I loved then
yeah and I'm not the person who I was
then even I he doesn't love me like I
don't want to tie someone down and make
it difficult for them to have a happy
life when they can go and find someone
that they do love yeah
like I sound horrible but like for the
last like three girlfriends I've had
I've told him straight but I have like
if I love you today I love you today
yeah if I don't love you tomorrow then I
don't I'm sorry and that's a very very
very black-and-white way to put it yeah
and I'm not so much of a sociopath that
I could ever just stop loving with
someone tomorrow yeah but I feel like is
there there is a certain reality to life
you know you just there's just no point
lying to yourself I think like stuff
like sometimes mmm not even to be
disrespect for anything like that
sometimes the concept of tradition is so
easy you can so easy just whitewash real
life yeah people love to whitewash real
life and make out like real life isn't
real life is yeah and if you don't like
someone like she had the audacity to
tell me like James you're thinking too
much about emotion you need to care
it was the most nervous it was the most
African thing I've ever heard anyone say
she was like marriage isn't about
emotion you need to take emotion out of
it like it's not like it's not practical
basically what are you saying this is my
life I'm gonna die one day yeah I'm
gonna die one day yeah I want to look
back at my life I don't want to think
like I took emotion out of it because it
was Impractical and I stayed with
someone that
didn't even want to be with me because I
made a vow to them way before I ever
knew this was going to happen
let me speak on two things Oh God well
one is regarding this and one is a
little bit of a tangent so when you said
talking about Patricia Blair tradition
hmm so obviously in this instill in this
day and age not in Western civilization
but in East of civilization there's
still a lot of arranged marriages yeah
in like India Africa like parts of Asia
oh yeah yeah and that's because again
tradition mm-hmm everyone is the parents
brainwash the kids like you have to
marry this person you have to marry
someone from your culture or someone
from your race or someone from this or
something from that and because kids
have not experienced anything else
they're brainwashed into it and they're
like this is all I know
yeah clearly I must do it yeah and
clearly I have to teach my kids this but
the thing is they're not necessarily
miserable but they're not happy because
that's what they know and they've kind
of like been forced into that situation
and they like said that's all they know
so it's it's practical as a whole family
thing but within the same breath they
may still grow to love that person that
they've been forced to been with but be
with person true actually yeah but it's
not it just blows my mind that things
like that still happen because they're
not exposed to everything and that's the
reason why I for one don't want to just
marry a Nigerian because she's a
Nigerian if I marry a Nigerian but
within the same ref I wouldn't want like
my mom or my dad or like my extended
family to look at me if I don't marry
and you marry a Nigerian thing why are
you marrying a Nigerian because they're
only asking themselves that question
because that's all they know yeah not
necessarily because they care about what
I feel Hieu me you to tell me who I
should marry hmm at the end of day nine
times I tell all the people are asking
that question I'm probably only gonna
see on my wedding day anyway so you're
irrelevant to me yeah you're relevant to
me so how do you even ask me that
yeah sure so that's so traditional one s
when you say tradition stuff like that
is very jarring I'm very like annoying
because they need to break out that
cycle Bobbsey a lot of people and for
generations to come still won't break
because that's all they know yeah it's
true it's bad and it's just it's crazy
that some people live that kind of life
and live that kind of world or reality
and completely off the topic so
obviously you guys know I live with a
female her name is Bella so this was
about three weeks ago I said to her this
is like not that day specifically but
this period of my life is probably the
best period of my life that I'm ever
gonna have and that's taking this quite
I know I'm gonna get married I know I'm
gonna have kids and I'm gonna do all of
that share my life but this moment in my
life is [ __ ] fantastic and I'll
explain why I'm happy to hear you
explain explain why ago God because the
reason why I just I thought about it
then and I'm thinking about now is
because I said 50 obviously I said my
parents my angel for 50 years so 50
years is that a long time we're only
coming up to 30 years and we've probably
if let's say we die at 80 90 so we've
still got another 50 plus years to go
yeah but so my job isn't the best job in
the world why still strike and still go
for it yeah your job isn't the best job
in the world but you still have fun
sometimes you know I mean yeah laughs
yeah doing a podcast is [ __ ] jokes
like I live with Bella it's [ __ ]
hilarious like dude I mean we train all
the time we have we have opportunities
that you wouldn't even dream of 10 years
ago and we're living there were
literally in the realm of living our
best lives because in 50 years I'm gonna
have grandkids I'm probably gonna forget
that 50 years ago I lived with Bella
yeah 50 years ago we started a podcast
yeah 50 years ago we will live I was
living in Manchester you live in here we
will live in our life because our lives
will be so different but crazy because
in 20 years I'm probably gonna be
married to hopefully in 20 years I'd be
married with a few kids that older hmm
and I'm gonna think back on this time
like [ __ ] I was happy back then yeah boy
I was happy back then so long story
short just take life as it comes man and
just [ __ ] grab by the balls and have
fun but that's what I'm saying bro like
I literally think it sounds like such a
simplistic stupid thing to say and an
immature thing to say to a lot of people
as well but like I I think over the last
year or two especially I'm just I own I
literally only feel like people should
just do what's fun all the time yeah and
even like it sounds stupid but you want
to get the best at this this really
is onto another topic that I'm gonna
bring up on the next episode that we're
doing a bit hmm because it's a long it's
a long one
yeah but like you should just do what
you want to do and it sounds like I said
it sounds stupid
it sounds like simplistic is it is such
a dumb thing to say an immature thing to
say but there are certain aspects in
that people keep saying things to me
like oh I can't do this or I can't do
that or like I want to do this um wanna
do that when you just said just do it
they're just like no I can't because of
this you can just do it but I've like
just do it like we want to start a
podcast we just do it like I've got a
guy at work who bro he's been working at
at this joint for 11 years and he's way
into recycling and stuff so I ever said
to him a few weeks ago I was like oh do
you it wasn't few boosters mom's ago no
I said do you want to retire he's in his
forties he's were there for 11 years I
said do you want to retire here yeah
which seems to me like a very reasonable
reason question question yeah you bet
they're over a decade and you're in your
forties and he was a hell he lives me
like a piece of [ __ ] like are you
[ __ ] crazy no I don't want to retire
here yeah like hell no I don't wanna
retire here yeah like why would you even
ask me that and I was like because
you've worked here for 11 years yeah and
you're 40 yeah and then he was at nanos
I said what do you want to do and he as
I like to be honest he's away in cycling
is I'd love to work in a bike shop like
I'd love to work like repairing bikes
and like I didn't even know what you do
in a bike shop but you do a backhoe
bicycle bicycle okay he didn't like
really into like road races and all that
kinda [ __ ] so he loves bikes and he was
I want to work in a bike shop and I was
like go on then bro I was it do it is
that now I can do it because about this
I got my mortgage as a [ __ ] your money
as I bro
no offense you ain't got girlfriend you
ain't got a wife you ain't got kids
you've got zero responsibility you've
got zero responsibility you can afford
to take a pay cut and go work at this
[ __ ] bike shop yeah trust me yes I've
got more responsibilities than you yeah
and then like just doing it he's like
and then after like half an hour of me
be like do it and [ __ ] do it do it do
it and he was just a probe to be honest
no I'm like I'm too scared to do and I'm
just never gonna do it it's one of those
things that I've come to terms with that
I'm just never gonna
and I was like dude like is such a
cliche to say you only live once but
honestly you actually do any liberal you
genuinely do like people forget it yeah
like deaf is people at my deficit a real
thing yeah Thank You Jen uni this is it
today's that only like today is the
youngest we're ever gonna be yeah [ __ ]
yeah today's the youngest we're ever
gonna be preach and like this [ __ ] if
you just don't do it you'll never do it
yeah and what is the point in dying
thinking I really want to do that for
you whilst you scared yeah you don't
fulfill your dream so ever hey man just
chase [ __ ] another thanks working it's
not even that hard working a bike shop
that's not your astronaut yeah it's like
working a [ __ ] bike go you could go
and go get a job today lunch break your
ones take a walk to the closest bike
shop and you'll probably get hired yeah
you know a lot about bikes and I was
like just do it like why not just
[ __ ] do it and you're gonna end up
retire will end up retiring here and
then you'll be thinking odd remember
when James asked me 20 years ago for
that's the one saying like when living a
better life some people are some people
are but I perceive you like I [ __ ] it up
I'm living my current best life which is
then some days aren't the best some days
are the worst but it's not up and down
is the in-between it's rough it's that
race that keeps me going because I I
love life perfect ideal of my life life
is [ __ ] sick as hard as it gets it or
as easy to get some days I [ __ ] love
my life because like I said 50 years
from now and I'm sitting down oldest
[ __ ] looking at my kids I'm looking at
my grandkids if I could playing around
during Christmas or whatever I'm gonna
think fifty years ago I was happy about
fifty years ago I was sitting here
telling people that life is [ __ ] sick
I was happy bro just laughing I mean
ours love killing because it's never
gonna happen again
isn't this period of my life is never
gonna happen again
that's making me sad it is it made me
sad but maybe so happy oh yeah when the
realization came I was like [ __ ] because
light as short as as short as life is
life is so long let's say we all live a
healthy laughing like I said we die over
eighty nine ninety mmm that is a long
time for longest I don't want to live
that long that's how long it is that's
what we know we're going to be fine
what's that 50 years 60 years [ __ ] you
know 60 years that's almost as old as my
mom now yeah if your mum's life sad all
over again that's us tonight bro do what
you want to do in life man do you want
to do in life you kiddies it's not even
a case of you right either fingers as
well you're right people say I live for
short life it actually isn't sure sure
it's long as long as [ __ ] and the vast
majority of it is gonna be you of a
barback yeah
the majority of your life you're gonna
have a bad [ __ ] back and you're gonna
be grouchy yeah and you're gonna go to
sleep at 9:00 and wake up a three
o'clock in the morning because she is
raining outside your knees her brother
it's just angle time for that yeah so
yeah brother you just it's gonna be long
so just enjoy it
all the time just enjoy obviously
there's gonna be sure that you just
don't want to do yeah that's life though
but that is life that is literally the
roll it's like you said like I'd moan
about my job all the [ __ ] time but
the other day I had an in-depth debate
about [ __ ] marriage yeah with some
random African girl at work and it was
riveting yeah because I was cussing her
yeah you went in deep and I was young
dealer they're in deep for like 15 20
minutes and I was like this ain't never
gonna happen
yeah and I was it was awesome [ __ ] off
show us a cam'ron right now but yeah
when it was it's yeah it's not like you
have to go for it and like that's what I
say in terms of what you just said about
like just have fun like it sounds
horrible but if I've been with my
partner for 10 years 15 years and you
wake up I wake up one morning I'm just
like don't actually get along with you
the way I should get along with you I
don't think I do
I don't I don't actually think I want to
be with you like a hundred percent just
go yeah just lock it and like it's might
suck for your partner stuff like that
the whole thing I'm saying like have fun
do what you want
try not do what you want to the best of
your ability without actually hurting
other people yeah he's the best thing if
you're just you hurting people left
right send them you don't be okay and do
what you want to go [ __ ] [ __ ]
everyone on road because that's what
makes you happy no yeah yeah like you do
for the best of you to the best of your
ability have as much fun as possible
yeah and obviously don't ever let anyone
else hold you back for actually what you
want to do don't let the
you've been with someone for like I said
oh my god I said to the girl I said like
I wonder like if I want to leave in 10
years I want to leave and I'll be happy
about that
like this doesn't doesn't mean that you
have to just hate that person because I
don't want to be with him anymore and I
was like and she was like now because
like that's all waste and as I hear we
cover this way [ __ ] yeah don't talk to
me about waste because like girls
special only goes I've only ever heard a
girl say it but this whole waste like ah
you spend three years with someone and
then you break up like what a waste what
did you waste and she was like oh
because like I she was on about a guy
she was with she was out to give her
this long we moved in together like
obviously I invested my time I invest in
my love and then all of this and I was
like yeah but you didn't invest like
investment is a stupid thing to say
because you didn't invest your love so
that it will be reciprocated in 10 years
time yeah you invest everything you
invested was to get immediate
gratification yeah you moved in because
you want to live with him then yeah you
invested love because you want to love
him then yeah like you invested your
time because you wanted to spend time
with him then yeah like there wasn't
that's not an investment you did what
you want to do for the time that you
wanted to do it because you enjoyed it
at the time that you would do anything
you weren't doing all these things
thinking [ __ ] I hate spending time with
this guy but I'm doing it because I want
to be married in a tent like this many
years time so I'm investing yes and then
he [ __ ] you over so you spent years
being unhappy because you didn't
actually get what you wanted like that's
an investment yeah
but you loved the guy you did what you
wanted to do with the guy at the time
you wanted to do it so don't call it
investment and don't call it a waste
because you probably eat sushi now when
you didn't eat sushi before you learned
so much about someone hey when you live
with them and B once you spend a lot
more time with them so it's not a waste
because at the end of the day so many
values are so many traits from another
person can impact your life yeah they're
like sushi if you didn't eat sushi
before but your partner brought you at a
figured [ __ ] this example yeah so yeah
it's not a waste now you learned so much
from people by I can understand why
people say it's a waste because they
feel like ah got a start over again bla
bla but like I said as small as short as
his life is this life is so long
start again then like for his prime
example Keanu Reeves only just recently
he found a girlfriend or got a
girlfriend after a decade and Keanu
Reeves is 55 55 45 to 55 55 and he's
just got a girlfriend now or recently
like and he's lived his life must be
doing movies for since the matrix that's
20 odd years ago she's but way before
then as well and now man is happy at 50
[ __ ] five and now he's got 50 he's
rich as [ __ ] so he's definitely lived
200 so now he's got 55 to 102 just chill
and be happy so you man it's not it's
not every day because your friends are
doing it doesn't mean you have to do as
well that's another thing peer pressure
is it takes a toll especially on females
I understand the biological clock factor
for females so that pressure I
understand because females want kids
whilst they're younger so the kids can
be healthier which is very very very
understandable I don't never knock that
but within the same breath you just also
need to live your life and let things
happen organically because like like we
were saying before let's say for example
this guy you were talking with stayed
with her ex at the time even though a
either a she didn't like him or he did
like her they had a baby bla bla bla bla
bla that baby may grow up to resent the
father because of what the mother tells
the baby
yeah a hundred percent bro but that's
got nothing to do with like the baby
might we'll never have enough he's a
peanut here's our opinion of the father
because the mother will be feeding him
rubbish absolute rubbish
super and [ __ ] like it's it's not that's
not what life is that's not what life is
it makes it harder because that's what
you're telling the kid mm-hmm whereas
you should have just locked it when you
know or he should have locked it when
they both knew it wasn't working out and
then start again because as short as
life is life is [ __ ] yo no he was just
found a ghetto 555 that's called 27
years away from me now exactly and I'm
28 and I know he's been living his life
this whole time
[ __ ] you know MA and like the whole
thing is like started oh I don't want to
start again and stuff like that bro I
guess what's finally gives actually fun
it's so much fun s yourself into when
you put actually effort into it yeah it
can be fun
when you get those first date jitters
lover first lips I love to kiss I love
to kiss Abba lips are I loved
oh [ __ ] you know bro first kiss yeah
those when you just and you're like
alright cool first day get a few drinks
down and the conversations flow give me
damn you all of that
I love [ __ ] like that man so yes it is
fun man shut up shut up shut up man
start again is [ __ ] fine and then if
that one doesn't work there's gotta be
there's another talking stage down the
drain
who cares who cares with this end goal
[ __ ] all the time
angry point five billion man dem in the
world 3.5 billion girl in the world
like you're fine you're fine but you
gonna be alright
you're fine but it's just sick and tired
of it man and it's not just girls man
dem to man a lot of a lot of guys like
wanna win though in filth because
they're heartbroken it's under that
people get heartbroken left Ryan so no
but there is always so much time unless
god forbid you're dying you've got
cancer or something terminally ill
that's that's a completely different
tangent yeah if you're healthy you're
fine like externally internally you're
just obviously heartbroken then big man
mercy time is a healer but just move on
but the thing is I think a lot of people
I actually had this Bell as the first
car of a she heard openly admit it was a
good conversation that we had the other
week and like people should this is it
sounds like a pretty backwards way to
say it but people should look forward to
being heartbroken more often but I get
hot like I said to the other week like
hi Ashley I wear Mihama sleeve well I
get heartbroken for a bad time
yeah but where's that video big easy
five mini heartbreaks no one can
actually really true to touch my soul
like that but it's [ __ ] fun at the
same time because you can only get hurt
when you allow yourself to be happy
that's the thing bact is like you said
this was the roller coaster and stuff
like that like don't be scared of
heartbreak because if you're getting
heartbroken
means before that you were [ __ ]
[ __ ] happy and if you didn't get
heartbroken then you wouldn't have never
been happy didn't really content yeah if
you someone broke up with you or someone
cheat on you or something like that and
you were something there then you were
never really happy our first place so
like you can't get the good about the
bad man if you're if you're scared of
getting a heart broken then you're also
scared of being happy I'm just gonna be
happy because it's much better than just
being like oh okay I find it hard to get
close to people and get my guard up
cause I don't want to get hurt big man
get hurt get hurt beginner because
you're before that your gasps your happy
ass do I have I can happy and it's more
fun to be happy yeah being happy is the
[ __ ] best the best feeling in the
world
God [ __ ] man allow yourself to be
vulnerable Asif to get hurt and [ __ ]
you're right I was loud you were right
our boring new family fiddly sorry firm
it was off the things back Jesus yeah
yeah drop your side man drop your guard
drop your God like let yourself get hurt
because yeah you're gonna get over it
like you did did are seven times and you
were happy before that yeah happy
because every time when I say when I go
for my new outbreaks up by that every
time before that was you were happy yes
do yoga yeah stop oh yeah I was [ __ ]
gas breath I was excited too I was
decide for all sorts yeah
and that was worth it man yup Briggs
always worth it yeah it's always working
because the harder you fall
the higher you of you were before yeah
like you can only fall hard if it's from
a high height mm-hmm like that's just it
I don't know how to explain any better
way might just get hurt from it it's fun
be vulnerable being vulnerable is is
exposing yourself like we're vulnerable
in what we do like this podcast because
we're free we talk about everyday stuff
and we don't hold back
that's why the focus is fun that's why
it's called shit's and gigs and that's
why it's fun and that's why a lot of
people either can relate to it or real
will later if and when they listen to it
because we are just speaking true for
speaking like it's a day-to-day
conversation it's just that the cameras
on privately exactly and it's like yeah
I put myself vulnerable and the more
vulnerable I allow myself to be yeah
making jokes about pedophilia telling
pee
with a bus or not in half a second like
all these things the morning realize
have to be the more fun the conversation
so the more yet the more I allow myself
to get hurt I don't know how this will
hurt me but yeah I said the more foreign
but allow myself to be although the more
open I am to scrutiny the more I will
laugh at the time that I'm doing it and
the more fun or I have and the more I
often encourage to do the next episode
yeah because if we just if I just had a
list of [ __ ] that I want to talk about
I'm not gonna talk about that because of
this yeah I ain't talking about that
it'll be boring [ __ ] I want to do it
yeah I won't want to do it yeah and I'm
just like it's just pointless so yeah
man just have fun all the time if I
could do what you want to do be
vulnerable have fun get hurt and boy
it's gonna be worth it it's gonna be
well it's gonna be perfect it's gonna be
talking about this with the weather you
sat down with in 25 years time I did
this this and this and this and this you
you've loved life man and you're happy
again yeah man chilly in there makes me
want to get hurt now I love it
that's why I said so that's why I said
Toby's a [ __ ] because he loves getting
hurt the thrill of being vulnerable he
[ __ ] loves it oh Jesus honey right
just before we wrap up yeah it was a
great topic I just wanted to give you a
little mmm let's go let's ask this one
big man how many people have for you
specialist is funny how many people
would you kill to get to be 60 how many
people would you [ __ ] killed to be 60
just for context I'm under 6 foot and
high love see if you scroll back to
episode 2 5 male insecurities and I said
one of them was Heights and if you
remember my specific example I said I
told ago I was five nine and she looked
to me just dead in my boat and I knew
she knew I wasn't fighting because she
was five 900 so how many people that I
kill that's deep though to kill to be
what I get caught
no no no no I get caught you have to
kill him with a knife though you have to
stop them oh that's brutal
so whatever number you say I lined up in
a room you just have to stab them make
sure they're dead and then the next one
comes in or if it's just one that you
said and then I said you have to kill
them
Jesus Christ you don't know them you
don't know their story I can do it not
getting anyone I can do six - I can do
it
alright I couldn't do it look at it Amy
could it do it alright let's say how
many Peter files would you kill oh
that's different
how many I kill loads with your bare
hands yup bangin if they couldn't move
if there were like time in a chair and
that dude fight back on rock my rock
until they die I think I'd rather if
they did fight back why I don't want to
kill someone okay when it gets to that
stage obviously that [ __ ] yes untie
untie them swing Jesus but now if it was
if it was people that deserve to die
yeah I would stab them but not like
day-to-day people like John from down
the road man no all right cool that's
harsh but I know where you're coming
from I know you're trying to feed sign
army but he's out if you know me you
know I would love to be sixty that's
like my ideal high because I just know
I'd be the best man I can be I'm not
saying I'm up I'm not happy I'm very
[ __ ] happy now I'm happy yeah but if
God gave me an extra five inches mmm rap
calm rap package sorry man let me wrap
this thing and then we could do a
different one